hey there how are you I'm fine thanks
for not asking or possibly asking but I
couldn't hear you because I'm in TV land
I'm an internet TV land but welcome to
the monitor I'm going to stop talking
about that stuff because this week what
do we have we have all sorts of fun
stuff we have a video game that is my
most anticipated title yet this year we
have an album that carves its way
through a very heavy release week in the
music world but first we have the season
premiere of one of my favorite comedies
on television and that is Parks and
Recreation on NBC and as usual it puts
its fantastic ensemble cast to good use
there are actually three decent plots in
this week's episode on one you have
Leslie Knope star Amy Poehler and Andy
going to Washington DC to meet up with
with Adam Scott's character I forget his
name and April who was working with him
in DC secondarily you have Ron Swanson
who is now running the Parks and Rec
Department taking over duties for the
Employee Appreciation summer barbecue
which in Leslie's day was known as the
employment enjoyment summerslam grilled
jam fun splosion I I had to commit that
to memory so I could impress upon you
how fantastic that is of course when Ron
Swanson is involved you know it's going
to be nothing but grilled meat to the
exclusion of everything including fun so
obviously hilarities not for the
attendees just for the viewers at any
rate good solid half hour TV great way
for Parks and Rec to start off the
season strong episode got to watch it
it's on this very night that you're
watching this so watch it live watch a
DVR I don't care just watch it let's
talk about music okay thank you now this
week is it's actually a pretty strong
week for music there's there's a lot of
good albums out this week you've got
grizzly bears new album out this week
you've got good music Kanye and Cruz
album cruel summer it was called cruel
summer because originally was supposed
to come out in August but it's out this
week these things happen but that might
want to talk about is actually by
manamana
which is a portland-based well duo used
to be a trio but one of the founding
members left last year's is like their
fifth album or something it's called
moms it's really great I'm not the
hugest indie rock guy but I really
really like this album some clever
songwriting great use of kind of pacing
the songs keep you interested there's I
love sax I love saxophone they throw
some saxophone in but not in the way
that it's like some coughing or morphine
or something crazy it's just you know
it's not intrusive it's just their moms
by manamana it's out retail it out on
iTunes it's on Spotify check it out okay
thank you for that let's talk about
video games because Borderlands 2 is out
this week which means that my months of
anticipation are finally over I can't
just have some psychopathic murderers
getting to the ball before I do I mean
don't get me wrong it's cute that y'all
think you're the heroes of this little
adventure but you're not it is a sequel
to gearboxes fantastic kind of shooter
little RPG overlay from a couple of
years ago it is back with four new
classes you've got your commando you've
got your gun zerker you've got well
you've got another siren and then you've
got this crazy assassin you can pick any
of them and level up within them the
coop is fantastic it's better writing
this this time around they've got a new
writer working on it and it's hilarious
like claptrap who if you play the
original you know well as kind of the
robot mascot / guide I guess is
incredible it is it is really actually
laugh out loud game dialogue and some
fantastic characters great so far I'm
really in love with the game and if
you're kind of biding your time and
waiting for october november to pick up
a triple a title don't borderlands 2 is
the one and it's going to keep you
occupied I promise you well past the
releases of other larger more
high-profile games but that is it for
this week on the monitor we will be back
next week with more pop culture goodness
in the meantime email us at the monitor
at wire calm but until then
inspirational catchphrase here